shortly after four o'clock this morning
i spoke to president zielenski of
ukraine as the first missiles struck his
beautiful and innocent country and its
brave people and i assured him
of the unwavering support
of the united kingdom
and i can tell the house
that at this stage
ukrainians are offering a fierce defense
of their families and their country
and i know that every honourable member
will share my admiration for their
resolve
earlier today
president putin delivered another
televised address and offered the absurd
pretext that he sought the
demilitarization
and de-nazification
of ukraine
in fact he is hurling the might of his
military machine against a free and
peaceful neighbor in breach of his own
explicit pledge and every principle of
civilized behavior between states
spurning the best efforts of this
country and our allies to avoid
bloodshed
for this putin
will stand condemned in the eyes of the
world and of history
he will never be able to cleanse the
blood of ukraine from his hands
and although the uk and our allies tried
every avenue for diplomacy until the
final hour i'm driven to conclude that
putin was always determined to attack
his neighbor no matter what we did
now we see him
for what he is
a blood-stained aggressor who believes
in imperial
conquest i am proud that britain did
everything within our power to help
ukraine prepare for this onslaught and
we will do our utmost offer more help as
our brave friends defend their homeland
our embassy took the precaution on 18th
of february of relocating from kiev to
the city of live in western ukraine
where our ambassador melinda simmons
continues to work with the ukrainian
authorities and to support british
nationals
now
we have a clear mission
diplomatically
politically
economically
and eventually
military
this hideous and barbarous venture of
vladimir putin
must end in failure
at the g7 meeting this afternoon we
agreed to work in unity to maximize the
economic price that putin will pay for
his aggression
and this must include
ending europe's collective
dependence on russian oil and gas
that has served to empower putin for too
long so i i welcomed again chancellor
schultz's excellent decision to halt the
certification of nordstrom 2.
mr speaker countries that together
comprise about half the world economy
are now engaged in maximizing pressure
economic pressure on one that makes up a
mere two percent for our part today the
uk is announcing the largest and most
severe package of economic sanctions
that russia has ever seen
with new financial measures we're taking
new powers to target russian finance in
addition to the banks we've already
sanctioned this week today in concert
with the united states we are imposing a
full asset freeze on vtb
more broadly these powers will enable us
totally to exclude
russian banks from the uk financial
system which is of course by far the
largest in europe stopping them from
accessing sterling and clearing payments
through the uk
with around half of russia's trade
currently in us dollars and sterling i'm
pleased to tell the house that the
united states is taking similar measures
these powers will also enable us to ban
russian state and private companies from
raising funds in the uk
banning dealing with their securities
and making loans to them
we will limit the amount of money that
russian nationals will be able to
deposit in their uk bank accounts
and sanctions will also be applied to
belarus for its role in the assault on
ukraine
[Music]
overall we'll we'll be imposing asset
freezes on more than 100 new entities
and individuals on top of the hundreds
that we've already announced
this includes all the major
manufacturers that support putin's war
machine
furthermore
we are also banning aeroflot from the uk
next on top of these financial measures
and in full concert with the united
states and the eu
we will introduce new trade restrictions
and stringent export controls similar to
those that they in the us are
implementing we will bring forward new
legislation
to ban the export of all dual use items
to russia
including a range of high-end and
critical technological equipment and
components in sectors
including electronics telecommunications
and aerospace
legislation to implement this will be
laid early next week
these trade sanctions will constrain
russia's military industrial and
technological capabilities for years to
come
we're bringing forward measures on
unexplained wealth orders from the
economic crime bill to be introduced
before the house rises for easter and we
will set out further detail before
easter on the range of policies to be
included in the full bill in the next
session including on reforms to
companies house and a register of
overseas property ownership
we will we will set up a new dedicated
kleptocracy cell in the national crime
agency to target sanctions evasion and
corrupt russian assets hidden in the uk
and that means oligarchs in london will
have nowhere to hide and mr speaker
i know that this house
will have great interest in the
potential of cutting russia out from
swift
and
i can confirm as i've always said
that nothing is off the table
but for all these measures to be
successful
it is vital
that we have the unity of our partners
the unity in the g7 and other forums and
uh mr speaker
russian
investors
are all already delivering their verdict
on the wisdom of putin's actions and so
far today russian stocks are down by as
much as 45
wiping 250 billion dollars from their
value in the biggest one day decline on
record
spare bank russia's biggest lender is
down by as much as 45
and gas gas prom down by as much as 39
while the ruble has plummeted to record
lows against the dollar
we will continue on a remorseless
mission to squeeze russia from the
global economy piece by piece day by day
and week by week and we will of course
use britain's position
in every international forum to condemn
the onslaught against ukraine
and we will counter the kremlin's
blizzard of lies and disinformation by
telling the truth about putin's war of
choice and his war of aggression and we
will work with our allies on the urgent
need to protect other european countries
that are not
members of nato and who could become
targets of putin's playbook of
subversion and aggression
and we will resist
any creeping temptation
to accept what putin is doing today
as a fate accompli
there can be no creeping normalization
not now not in the months to come not in
the years ahead we must strengthen
nato's defenses still further and so
today i called for a meeting of nato
leaders which will take place tomorrow
and i will be convening the countries
that contribute to the joint
expeditionary force which is led by the
united kingdom and comprises both nato
and non-nato members
last saturday
i warned
that this invasion would have global
economic consequences and
this morning the oil price
has risen strongly
the government will do everything
possible to safeguard our own people
from the repercussions for the cost of
living
and of course we stand ready
to protect our country from any threats
including
in cyberspace
above all the house will realize
the hard and heavy truth
that we now live in a continent where an
expansionist power
deploying one of the world's most
formidable military machines
is trying to redraw the map of europe in
blood
and conquer an independent state by
force of arms
and it's vital for the safety of every
nation the putin's squad adventure
should ultimately fail and be seen to
fail
however long it takes
that will be the steadfast and
unflinching goal of the united kingdom
i hope of every member of this house and
every one of our great allies certain
that together we have the power and the
will
to defend the cause of peace and justice
as we have always done and i say to the
people of russia again whose president
has just authorized an onslaught against
a fellow slavic people i cannot believe
that this horror is being done in your
name
or that you really want the pariah
status that these actions will bring to
the putin regime and to our ukrainian
friends in this moment of agony i say
that we are with you and we are on your
side your right to choose your own
destiny is a right that the united
kingdom and our allies will always
defend and in that spirit i join you in
saying slava ukraine and i commend this
statement to the house
i now call the leader of the opposition
kirstama
thank you mr speaker
in this dark hour
our thoughts our solidarity and our
resolve are with the ukrainian people
invading troops marched through their
streets
missiles shelled their cities
they've been cast into a war through no
fault of their own
because putin fears their freedom
and because he knows that no people will
choose to live under his bandit rule
unless forced to do so
at the barrel of a gun
the consequences of putin's war of
aggression
will be horrendous and tragic
for the people of ukraine
but also for the russian people
who've been plunged into chaos by a
violent elite
who have stolen their wealth
stolen their chance of democracy
and stolen their future
and we must prepare ourselves for
difficulties here
we will face economic pain
as we free europe from dependence on
russian gas and oil
and clean our institutions from money
stolen from the russian people
but the british public have always been
willing to make sacrifice
to defend democracy
on our continent
and we will again
the consequences of putin's actions will
be felt throughout the world for years
and i fear for decades to come
russia's democratic neighbors
and every other democracy that lives in
the shadow of autocratic power are
watching their worst nightmare unfold
so all of us who believe in democracy
over dictatorship
in the rule of law over the reign of
terror
in freedom over the jackboot of tyranny
must unite and take a stand
we must support the ukrainian people in
their fight
and we must ensure
that putin fails
putin will eventually learn the same
lesson that european tyrants earned in
the last century
that the resolve of the world is harder
than he imagines
that the people's desire for freedom
burns brighter than he can ever
extinguish
and that the light of liberty will
prevail
over his darkness
for that to happen we must make a clean
break with the failed approach to
handling putin
which after georgia after crimea after
donbass has fed his belief
that the benefits of aggression outweigh
the costs
we must finally show him
that he is wrong
that means doing all that we can to help
ukraine defend ourselves
by providing weapons equipment
and financial assistance
as well as humanitarian support for the
ukrainian people
we must urgently reinforce and reassure
our nato allies in eastern europe who
now stand at the frontier of putin's
aggression
and the hardest possible sanctions must
be taken against the putin regime
it must be isolated
its finances frozen
its ability to function crippled
that means excluding russia from the
financial mechanisms like swift
and banning trade in russian sovereign
debt
i welcome the set of sanctions outlined
by the prime minister just now
and pledge opposition support for
further measures
and there are changes we must make here
in the uk
for too long our country has been a safe
haven
for the money that putin and his fellow
bandits stole from the russian people
it must now change
cracking open the shell companies in
which stolen money is hidden
will require legislation
bring it forward immediately prime
minister and labour will support it
along with the other measures that the
prime minister has just outlined
thank you and we will support it
mr speaker
this must be a turning point in history
we must look back and say
that this terrible day
was actually when putin doomed himself
and doomed his plan to reassert russian
force as a means of controlling eastern
europe to defeat
we know how putin operates
so we know
how to defeat him
he seeks division
so we must stand united
he hopes for inaction
so we must take a stand
he believes that we are too corrupted to
do the right thing
so we must prove him wrong
i believe we can
and in this dark hour
we can step towards the light
thank you mr speaker
i want to say how grateful i am to the
right honourable gentleman for the terms
in which he has just spoken and the
robust support that he is uh offering to
the government uh and to the western
alliance mr speaker at a very very
difficult time and i think the whole
house can be turning to some of the
issues that he raised very briefly i
think the whole house can be proud of
the uh the role that the uk has played
in uh pioneering military uh support
logistical support uh to the ukrainians
the the way the role that we played in
bringing together a ferocious package of
sanctions uh which we will now implement
and we will bring our allies together uh
mr speaker to protect nato to show uh
that president putin will get a tougher
western alliance as a result of his
actions not a weaker western alliance
and i think mr speaker that events will
show that the russian president has
profoundly miscalculated he believes
that he is doing this for his own
political advantage i believe the exact
opposite will prove to be the case
because of the resistance that will be
mounted against what he is doing not
just in ukraine but around the world and
we will support those ukrainians uh mr
speaker we will support them uh
economically diplomatically politically
and yes military as well and i know that
in due time we will succeed
theresa may
thank you mr speaker can i welcome my
right honourable friends statement this
afternoon
this house and this country are united
in our defense of democracy and our
support for the ukrainian people
vladimir putin has initiated war in
mainland europe the response must be
unequivocal
and absolutely clear
so will my right honourable friend
confirm
that the government is putting in place
every possible economic sanction
so that russia feels absolutely the cold
wind of isolation
and the russian people understand that
vladimir putin has brought their state
to a pariah state
prime minister uh
i thank my random friend and she's
absolutely right about what the
government is setting out to do and i do
indeed believe that that will be the
result for putin and his cronies
we now come to the smp later
thank you mr speaker let me thank the
prime minister for advanced copy of the
statement and let me also welcome the
very close contact he has kept with the
ukrainian president of course
importantly overnight
i was grateful that i had a chance to
meet this afternoon with the
ukrainian ambassador to the uk and
indeed with ukrainian mps
our thoughts and our support is very
much with each and every one of them as
it is with all of the people of ukraine
speaker although last night's events
have been prophesied and predicted for
some time
the acts of russian violence aggression
and tyranny
are no less shocking
what we are witnessing
is a full-scale invasion it is an act of
war
this is first and foremost an unprovoked
attack on the peace and the innocence of
ukraine and of its people
but it's equally an attack on
international law
an attack on our european democracy an
attack on the peace
that our continent has so carefully
built
over the last 75 years
president putin
and president putin alone
bears responsibility
for these horrific acts
and it is he
and his kremlin cabal who must pay a
massive price
for their actions
it is important to say to the russian
people
that we know
that putin is not acting in their name
he is a dictator
he is an imperialist
he is a tyrant
he is much a threat to his own people
as he is to all of us
mr speaker
this is a moment for unity
and it's especially a moment
for european unity
all of the economic sanctions that are
now finally being implemented have one
clear objective the complete
economic isolation of the russian state
can the prime minister confirm that this
is the objective and that he has agreed
that with his international allies
that economic isolation
must include sanctions on putin and his
network of oligarchs and agents that
expulsion from countries around the
world sanctions on his banks and their
ability to borrow and function and
sanctions on his energy and mineral
companies
and as i said yesterday it must
finally mean cleaning up the sewer of
dirty russian money that has been
running through the city of london for
years
and i know all the complications
involved but can i ask the prime
minister that the actions to be taken to
suspend russia from the swift payment
system one of the steps that would hit
the putin regime the hardest
but just as we
rightly seek to punish putin we must
redouble our support and solidarity for
the ukrainian people
can the prime minister give further
details on the humanitarian aid being
deployed and the plans in place to offer
refuge and sanctuary where necessary to
those that have been displaced
and what plans are in place to evacuate
the families of uk citizens currently in
ukraine given that commercial flights
have now stopped mr speaker
let's not fall for the kremlin
propaganda that they are prepared to
soak up any sanctions
if we act now
if the sanctions are targeted enough
swift enough
severe enough if we impose nothing less
than economic isolation
putin and his cronies will suffer the
consequences of their actions
so let us act together
stand together and most of all let us
stand
with the people of ukraine
mr speaker can i thank again the the
right honourable gentleman for the uh
the wisdom and the statesmanship with
which he has just uh he's just spoken
and uh just on his points in particular
we've put a thousand uh uh troops on
standby to help with the humanitarian
exodus in the adjacent countries uh we
have uh people in forward presence in
the adjacent countries to help uk
nationals come out and he's quite right
mr speaker that the way to uh make these
sanctions work as we discussed today in
the g7 uh where there is a great deal of
unity is that we do them together and we
do them at the same time and that's what
we're doing
can i just say to everybody the premise
has got some very important meetings
we'll be running this to 6 30. those
colleagues who don't get him we are
keeping the list like we did from the
other day to try and ensure that
everybody does get a voice in a very
very
you'd love to see it
it's a very very important matter i now
come to the chair of the foreign
thank you mr speaker first of all pay
huge tribute to my writer and friend the
prime minister and his government today
for introducing what sound like the
toughest sanctions we've seen in uh
years may i ask him however to look
wider than simply the russian people and
to look at all those who are enabling
putin's economy those who sit on boards
of the businesses that finance him
whether they are former chancellors of
germany or former prime ministers of
france may i ask him to look here close
to home at those who enable who
propagate the propaganda that is being
used by putin to undermine his own
people and free people everywhere and to
update the treason act so that we can
identify them and call them what they
are traitors
can i also ask the prime minister one
last question which is when he speaks to
people around the world that he speaks
with the truth that he can
in russian through the bbc russian
service and starts to broadcast in
languages other than russian into russia
so that all russian peoples can know
their oppression doesn't need to exist
they don't need to side with a tyrant
prime minister
mr speaker i thank him very much and
he's absolutely right that we have to uh
we have to look at the those who have
bet uh the putin regime and there are
there are many many of them and that's
why uh we're looking at all sorts of
ways in which we can address threats uh
to to this state uh mr speaker and we
are of course
making sure that the messages from this
house which is so which are so
impressive in their unity should should
be registered uh by the people of russia
because we mean uh no ill towards them
they are as much in many ways the
victims as the people of ukraine of this
appalling regime and they need to know
what's really going on
damn angela edel
mr speaker
would the
prime minister
tell us
uh if he can
uh
what's going on with the russian troops
going through chernobyl which
center chill through a lot of people's
thoughts when we heard about it
prime minister i thank the rightful
really very very much i i hesitate to
give uh the house a running comment from
what seems a very fluid and very uh very
dangerous situation but to best my
knowledge she's right and what she says
dr julian thank you mr speaker for the
best part of 50 years britain gave
sanctuary to the governments in exile of
the occupied baltic states if as appears
likely ukraine gets overwhelmed will we
offer to give sanctuary to a government
in exile pending ukraine's future
freedom
prime minister
of course i thank my moral friend of
course mr speaker we will give all uh
support that we can uh logistical or
otherwise as britain always has done uh
to governments in exile and at the point
i made to president uh one of the points
i mentioned to president
this morning was it it might be
necessary for him to find uh a safe
place for him and his uh and his cabinet
to go
ed david mr speaker with president putin
responsible for this catastrophic human
tragedy liberal democrats joined all
sides to stand in solidarity with the
people of ukraine and i thank the prime
minister for his statement
today must be a wake-up call
the west has been too complacent over
putin's threat for too long
we have taken for granted our fragile
alliances
so crucial for the defense of freedom
embolding putin this outrageous act of
aggression
the west cannot be complacent any longer
so will the government
reverse its proposed troop cuts to the
british army and offer far greater
military support to our nato allies in
eastern europe and mr speaker
putin must face the most punitive of
sanctions the world must isolate russia
like the rogue state it is
including the state-backed oil giant
rosneft
20 owned by bp
so will the prime minister commit to
banning uk investment
in russian oil and gas companies
with immediate effect
mr speaker the uh on his point about
investment in
uh in in russian oil and gas as i've
said we must move away uh from all our
dependencies on russian oil and gas and
that is the objective of the uk
government well we're lucky in this
country that we have only three percent
of our gas that comes from russia other
european countries and are in a much
more exposed uh position on his point
about supporting uh eastern europeans
we have as he knows doubled the size of
our commitments to estonia we've gone uh
bigger in in poland another 350 marines
from four five uh commando uh we're in
the skies above uh romania uh there's i
don't believe there's another country in
nato that is currently doing more uh to
strengthen uh nato's eastern defenses
listing bucket
thank you mr speaker my constituency
kensington has strong historical
connections with ukraine so i welcome
this robust approach
my constituency also has seen
significant property investments by
russian investors can i urge my right
honorable friend to accelerate the
introduction of a register of beneficial
ownership of property
yes she's completely right and uh we
need to unpeel the facade of these
companies these shell companies so we
can see who owns uh the property concern
hillary ben thank you very much indeed
mr speaker
it's because john stuart mill was right
when he warned
that bad men
need nothing more to compass their ends
than that good men should look on and do
nothing that the whole house will
support the measures that the prime
minister has just announced now in his
statement he said our mission is clear
diplomatically politically economically
and eventually
militarily what did he mean by using the
word militarily was he referring to
providing further defensive weapons to
enable ukraine to defend itself
yes
i obviously don't want to go into uh
detail because the uh it is a very
sensitive and difficult business but yes
uh mr speaker we have done uh we
continue to do so and i believe i have
the support of the house uh in intending
uh to continue to do so bob seeley you
very much indeed mr speaker i thank the
prime minister for his words and his if
i understand correctly early commitment
to an economic crime bill and a
kleptocracy sell in relation to that
will there be a foreign lobbying bill
will there be amendments to libel and
data protection act to stop unscrupulous
law firms offering intimidation services
to oligarchs and kleptocrats
and will the nca be properly funded as
the isc report suggested so it will be
able to take on the kleptocrats the
autocrats and the oligarchs in this
country
all right mr speaker i'm grateful as i
said in my uh opening statement uh we
are setting up a uh a new uh combating
kleptocracy cell in the national uh
crime agency to target the very uh
individuals that he uh that he mentions
sarah chapter
thank you mr speaker let us be under no
illusion we are on the brink of a
potentially enormous humanitarian crisis
which could see massive loss of life and
widespread suffering for the ukrainian
people and all to suffer the warped
bizarre complex of the russian president
the attack on ukraine is also likely to
cause mass displacement of people
potentially triggering a significant
refugee crisis in europe so can the
prime minister tell us what he is doing
to support the ukrainian people who stay
and those who choose to flee
she makes a very important point and i'm
grateful mr speaker because the
humanitarian impact threatens to be
enormous and uh that's why i i've said
what i've said uh about supporting uh
those refugees as they as they come out
of of ukraine
but we've got to make sure that we do
everything we can to stabilize uh the
ukrainian economy uh to support uh the
government and the uh as far as we
possibly can and that's why yesterday on
tuesday i should say i announced uh the
500 million uh dollar extra package of
development date on top of the 100
billion pounds we've already given uh
other countries uh our friends and
allies
are working with us to do much more
sure
does the prime minister agree that the
international order as envisaged in the
atlantic charter of 1941 has been the
most successful in the history of
freedom and democracy and as one of the
architects of that order we have a
special responsibility to defend it and
whilst today's sanctions are extremely
welcome it cannot just be economic
measures we need a fundamental review of
our military capability including
revisiting the integrated review whose
assumptions may now be out of date
mr speaker the the the
integrated review begins uh with the
assertion that the most important area
for our national security uh is the euro
atlantic uh area as i i believe i said
to the honourable general opposite uh on
tuesday and that remains fundamental and
that's why uh we've uh we've continued
with the investment uh that we have in
uh in nato whether we're the second
biggest uh founder of nato's uh as as
the honourable gentleman knows and but
he's he's my own friend knows but he's
right in what he says about what's at
stake this is about the whole idea of
that wonderful thing that uh
was so inspiring when some of us we were
young
of a europe whole and free that
fantastic revolution that happened in
1989 and 1990 when communism fell and mr
speaker it was a it was a great moment
for humanity and we mustn't allow it to
slip through our fingers five lewis
thank you mr speaker
i would like to say
the people of norwich uh that we show
our solidarity with the people of
ukraine um the warm words will not
defend the ukrainian people i've been
speaking to people who have been
liaising with ukrainian trade unions
people who've been fighting
privatization and wage cuts but they say
one thing they will not run from their
homes they will defend their families
those people need to be able to defend
themselves i support the prime
minister's uh assertion that we will be
providing more defensive capabilities
for that end but let me say one thing uh
prime minister and mr speaker
will you agree prime minister that we
must have an end to this by a negotiated
settlement and not by an escalation of
military means
mr speaker i think the whole house uh
everybody in the world
would want president putin to have
chosen the path of negotiation
uh he had that moment
and that's why if you remember we had
that uh discussion in this house on
tuesday about that that perilous moment
which we all discussed he had that
opportunity i'm afraid he's missed it
he's chosen the path of overwhelming
violence and destruction and i'm afraid
that puts us on a very very different
course and we have to accept that
reality david davis
[Applause]
everybody will wholeheartedly support
the prime minister's sanctions hopefully
against all 140 russian oligarchs that
support putin and against all the major
banks the prime minister also described
the russian state as a pariah state and
he's right because they have broken
international criminal law on a major
scale
can we actually implement our view of
the pariah state by ensuring that
everybody involved in that decision if
they leave russia to go abroad face
international criminal sanctions
wherever they go
i i thank my right honourable friend and
that is exactly what we can now do
thanks to the measures uh that this
house has passed
neil hamby
thank you mr speaker
this morning we walk to the worst
possible news
and i make no apology in hoping for a
diplomatic solution however my party and
i condemn the escalating russian
aggression this is a fluid and
developing situation but we are now in
uncharted territory and i can update the
house that once there have been calls in
this place
for alexander to cease broadcasting on
russia today negotiations have obviously
been happening in the background and i
can confirm that he has suspended
broadcasting
today
but we must prepare
we must prepare for the worst and i
would ask the prime minister what
what strategy is he bringing forward to
increase the capacity of north sea oil
and gas so that we can support ourselves
and eu member states and protect our
people from a further increase in the
cost of living
mr speaker
i i must say i disagree
profoundly with what he uh has had to
say about uh negotiating now i don't
think that that that option is uh is
open to us we we must do our our best to
support and protect uh the people of uh
of ukraine and uh and working with our
international friends and allies to
constrict uh what vladimir putin can do
and uh on on his point about uh about
russia today uh mr speaker uh i i simply
observe that uh the the former leader of
the scottish nationalist party is a uh
his leader sorry i'm so sorry
i'm sorry his leader i i understand the
the pleas he entered in defense and
mitigation uh they don't seem to cut
much ice
it's a uh lady
[Applause]
steve krabb is
mr speaker
i strongly welcome the further set of
sanctions announced by the prime
minister this evening and we look
forward to
further steps being taken in the days
ahead and not being held back by perhaps
some of the slower moving
members of the alliance in europe but
does the prime minister agree with me
that if sanctions are really to bite on
putin and his gangster government then
inevitably it will mean
cost and inconvenience to uk economic
interests but that cost and
inconvenience is of will be of as
nothing compared to what people of
ukraine are going through and we stand
with them this evening
yes i'm afraid he's my honorable my
normal friend is is right it will mean
cost it will mean
inconvenience it will mean difficulty
for us in the uk but that will be a
price worth paying mr speaker for
defeating the objectives of vladimir
putin and showing that aggression does
not play
damn diana johnson
could i just follow up on the question
from the honourable member for the isle
of wight about the combating kleptocracy
cell in the national crime agency and
just seek from the prime minister
a view whether additional powers will be
required for the national crime agency
and additional resources for them to do
their work yeah
i i thank her very much
they will of course they have
plenty of existing statute but the
additional powers
that they will have amongst other things
will be the ability to uh to peel back
the facade of ownership which i think
will be extremely valuable jonathan
mr speaker um whilst this
terrible appalling incident is of course
directly the cause of russia
i think it's appropriate that we also
recognize that over the last 14 years
the uk
the eu the us collectively have not been
attentive to russia in the way that we
should
can my right honourable friend now say
that whatever happened in the past
moving forward we are not going to let
russia fall between our fingers again
mr speaker i think the lesson of 2014
is that the whole of the west failed to
respond in the way that we should and
when a sovereign country uh was invaded
and part of that country uh was occupied
i'm afraid it was quite wrong uh that we
tried to manage the situation with the
various diplomatic processes that we did
which in the end produced absolutely
nothing except finally
this catastrophic invasion today we have
to a bitter lesson mr speaker about how
to deal with vladimir putin
thank you mr speaker i agree with the
prime minister that it seems like the
curtain
has now come down on that era that began
in 1989 and we've lived in an era of
change since then this now feels like a
change of era
in this new era
the permissive environment that we
created for the kremlin's quartermasters
to live
to invest and to party in london
sometimes with the prime minister
himself
that must now that must now come to an
end
so let me ask
so let me ask the prime minister this
will he undertake to ensure
that every visa issued to a russian dual
national
is now reviewed
and where proximity to president putin
is proven
that citizenship should be stripped away
yes mr speaker we are doing that though
i think it is i just think it is worth
the house uh remembering the point that
i made the other day not every russian
is a bad person
speaker
can i welcome the package of sanctions
the prime minister has set out and
whilst i understand why it's not been
possible to suspend russia from the
swift payment system at this stage can i
ask what work we're doing with our
european allies to offer them
reassurance so that eventually we can
get to a position where they can be
suspended because that is by far and
away the biggest thing that will isolate
the russian economy
good question my honourable friend is
spotter
the biggest thing would be uh to if
everybody stopped taking russian
hydrocarbons but swift uh swift is uh is
extremely important
and it's a belgian companies i'm sure
the house uh knows uh we're raising it
we're trying to make progress with our
our friends but for obvious reasons it
has to be done uh in unison
sure and
mr speaker
this morning i spoke with their friends
in kiev who were leaving the country
with
their family their children
and we've all seen the scenes from the
capital of cars trying to get out so i
send my
deepest thanks to the embassy team there
who are doing all they can to support
people but can i ask the prime minister
about two areas of support for ukraine
economic support
and continuing support for defensive
capability
will both of those areas of support
intensify and can he assure the house i
see the foreign secretary uh telling me
so but can he assure the house that the
government will continue the deepest
possible conversations with the
government in ukraine to ensure that no
matter the assault that comes to from
vladimir putin we will be supporting
them in a deeply meaningful sense
yes
on that last point the answer is
certainly yes mr speaker and you know
just for instance uh uh the other day i
was looking at two british minesweepers
being refitted in uh recyclers i'm sure
he uh he knows which are due to go to to
ukraine the question will be access mr
speaker that's what it all uh depends on
sir
mr speaker it's crystal clear from this
act of naked aggression
that putin doesn't seek finlandization
on his borders he seeks a best to
recreate a belarus in the south or at
worst to dismember the sovereign state
of ukraine does my right honourable
friend agree with me that that does mean
that we need to build upon the outcome
of our integrated defense review we do
need to think differently about eastern
europe from the past and then at home
with his announcement on bringing
forward economic crime measures it seems
that there is a consensus in this house
that could allow us to bring forward
emergency legislation to bring
those important measures to really hit
those people hard and hit them now
because i think that that is clearly the
the will of the house and it is the will
of the government and that's why i will
be uh taking those important measures
bringing them forward on monday
mr speaker my thoughts are with the
ukrainian people at this time and while
i welcome the sanctions the prime
minister's announced today can he update
the house on whether he plans to
sanction the major state-owned russian
banks such as cerber bank and gazprom
bank and the non-state bank alpha bank
thank you
yes mr speaker
thank you mr speaker the ukrainian powu
chapel at block could be in my
constituency is a focal point for the
ukrainian diaspora in scotland and
prayers are being said there for their
fellow countrymen but what ukrainians in
the uk have identified being grateful
for the military support that has
already been forthcoming is that there
is an immediate need for medical
battlefield supplies for warm clothing
for troops and for camouflage gear and
can my right honourable friend the prime
minister uh assure the house that they
will be forthcoming
uh i i thank my royal friend very much
he's he raises very important issue and
uh
we are we are working on exactly those
uh suppliers right now
thank the prime minister for his
statement and very much welcome the
sanctions that is announced today but
can you give an assurance that the
sanctions that are going to target
individuals will also uh
target
relatives and connected parties and like
the
item for swindon
he mentioned the economic crime bill
we've got the
the review of the official secrets act
and the foreign registration
why can't we bring them forward and do
them now they would get huge support
and we've been waiting for some of these
for nearly two years
mr speaker i can i can tell him that we
will certainly be uh making sure that we
uh are able to sanction and do sanction
uh relatives and uh and other interested
parties and and there will be there will
be a rolling program uh of intensifying
sanctions chris
have you been one of the officials that
accompanied the then defense secretary
to both moscow and kiev in 1993 i'm in
no doubt that the signatories of the
united states and the united kingdom on
the budapest memorandum uh gave ukraine
the confidence to give up its nuclear
territory
um will my right honourable friend
support the united states whatever
extent it is prepared to go
um to stand alongside the united states
in giving whatever military support it's
prepared to do so to ukraine
my right normal friend is absolutely
right to remind the house of the 1994
budapest memorandum which
had exactly that effect and created
exactly that obligation uh on us as one
of the signatories
mr speaker the prime minister will be
aware that we are on this side of the
house uh very keen on these sanctions
although does he share with me the worry
that the record of driving out dictators
and demagogues with shape
with these sanctions isn't always that
successful does he share my concern
that if you've if we've read what putin
has been saying these last few hours
he's a man that might not stop a ukraine
he might go into a nato country and
are we playing that scenario because
many of us think that might be the next
step
the rather normal gentleman is
absolutely right to raise that appalling
possibility
and it is vital that we reaffirm again
that under article 5 of the nato treaty
we stand four square behind every one of
our nato allies and and uh will come to
their defense ian duncan smith
speaker can i say to my honorable friend
that with ukrainian men and women dying
to fight against the russians for their
freedom today those who are calling for
negotiation at this point can only
please that rambling wreck of a neo-nazi
sitting in the kremlin and they should
be shunned
secondly can i just say to my older
friend today the ambassador from ukraine
asked desperately whether
nato would look at a no-fly zone i know
it's a difficult choice but could my
roundabout friend step to the dispatch
box and make it clear that in this
particular case
he rules nothing out
mr speaker i i know that uh my right
honourable friend is a is a great
military expert and i and i i he and he
will understand uh and i understand the
attractions of of the no-fly zone i
remember uh the no-fly zone that was
created in 1991 as i recall in uh in
northern iraq uh the situation here is
very is very different uh we would face
the risk of having to shoot down russian
planes mr speaker and that is something
that i think the uh the house would want
to uh to contemplate uh with with
caution
lord russell
speaker in locking out russian state
money i hope the prime minister can give
me a reassurance that that will include
our overseas territories and
dependencies that must be included in
this and i note that there are mr
speaker protest in a number of russian
cities across russia at the moment and
celebrities in russia have been speaking
out i do hope that we will be offering
all the support that we can to those
people who are likely to be shunned by
the fascist imperialist putin regime
yes and uh and can i say mr speaker that
one of the reasons why i want to keep
our fantastic british embassy staff in
moscow even though the temptation is
there simply to sunder uh diplomatic
relations uh with putin i want to keep
them there to support groups such as the
uh the ones he mentions
bob stewart
mr speaker i've given
evidence for war crimes trials
it was uh genocide
and crimes against humanity the people
were charged with
could i ask my right honourable friend
and the house
to agree with me that any russian
who kills a ukrainian must remember
that one day they may well be brought to
court
for crimes against humanity or genocide
yes mr speaker and not just any russian
competent uh mr speaker but anyone who
sends a russian uh
into battle uh to kill innocent
ukrainians bill esterson thank you mr
speaker president zielenski has called
for the toughest possible sanctions for
them to be the toughest possible that
must mean immediate
so in his statement he talked about in
the next session for the economic
measures
including on companies house
and on
the register of overseas property
ownership but in answer to the right
honourable member for swindon he said
something about bringing forward on
monday which of these is it and if it is
monday will it have the same effect as
is required for the immediate action
we'll be bringing it forward on monday
mr speaker and we want to have uh and we
want i hope and i i'm grateful for the
support of the opposition uh we want
immediately to start uh cracking down on
these
individuals jesse norman thank you mr
speaker the whole house will welcome the
enhanced package of sanctions that the
prime minister has announced today but
can i raise the question of football
much beloved to russian hearts and in
particular
issues of ownership of property and of
shareholdings and of the future
participation of russian clubs in
international matches
he's right uh my my royal friend is
completely right uh the russians attach
a great deal of sentimental importance
to uh to football and uh they they hope
to have the the uefa championship uh
final in uh in saint petersburg i cannot
for the life of me uh see how that can
currently go ahead liz savile roberts
putin's war on ukraine is brutal illegal
and a calculated attack on peace and
stability in europe plaid camry fully
supports the actions and sanctions
announced today putin his cronies and
their personal fortunes must pay for
their actions
on a visit to ukraine placary leaders
spoke to ukrainian soldiers government
officials and organizations admiring
ukrainian people for their strength and
their resilience and they are now in
harm's way
with poland organizing medical
assistance and slovakia opening its
borders to refugees will his government
mobilize and resource a global effort to
support and aid people fleeing this
horrific conflict
again mr speaker i thank her very much
for her uh her support and her her
resolve and uh i i want to assure her
that we're of course working with our
international friends to to
prepare for a humanitarian crisis
davidson
speaker earlier this afternoon i had the
opportunity to speak to on a zoom call
with a number of ukrainian mps who were
all calling for additional support one
of the key things they were discussing
is concerns that their communications
networks may get shut down so can i urge
a prime minister to ensure we're doing
all we can to provide things like
satellite phones to make sure they can
still communicate not just internally
but with us here in the uk too
mr speaker she's absolutely honorable uh
my own friend's absolutely right uh
there is a threat to communications
already and we're observing it in the uh
the contacts that we're having with uh
with people in in ukraine satellite
phones uh certainly are an option and
we'll be uh we'll be looking at that
sarah owen
thank you mr speaker we've rightly heard
a lot about tougher trade sanctions
today but nothing about ridding russian
state influence from our democracy will
the prime minister commit to
investigating all political donations
received from people with links to putin
and will his government finally bring
forward measures to clean up the corrupt
russian money that for far too long has
been laundered in the uk yeah yeah
so mr speaker all all political
donations are properly registered and uh
and and and monitored and uh i i and i
can tell her that uh we are
putting forward and progressively over
the last few days and weeks and today
the biggest ever package to crack down
on dirty russian money not just from
russia but from anywhere
speaker i welcome these sanctions today
my right on the friend's been crystal
clear that all europe needs to end
dependence on russian oil and gas could
he tell us a little bit more about how
he intends to see that that comes to
pass
thank you i thank you in fact my right
honourable friend the key thing is for
to get people first of all to recognize
the scale of their dependency as in any
addiction uh and
um that's what we're we're doing and the
uk government's been making that point
the whole time to our friends because
it's got worse since 2014 uh but what
we're also doing is helping countries
for instance in the in the baltic states
uh to go further and faster uh with
renewable technology
daniel zeitner
thank you mr speaker i think everyone
knows that the ukraine is a major
producer of grain and unfortunately
because of these awful events there are
likely to be consequences for many
countries including our own could ask
the prime minister to look again at our
food security proposals and make sure
that we are secure ourselves and not
reliant as so much as we have been in
the past
yeah he's absolutely right and uh and
food security is an important
consideration and one of the one of many
things that uh our fantastic ukrainian
community have have done in the last few
years is is help us in that very sector
andrew bridges
thank you mr speaker does my right-hand
friend agree with me that western
europe's ongoing reliance on russian oil
and gas has been a major factor in
embolding president putin in the
mistaken belief that he can invade his
peaceful neighbor with relative impunity
and in the uk shouldn't we refocus our
energy policy on maximizing the use of
our own natural resources looking again
at fracking while we invest in low
carbon alternatives
yes the
honorable gentleman is totally right uh
my own friend is totally right when he
uh he talks about the excessive
dependence on on on hydrocarbons we're
moving away from it in this country i do
think in that there is a a merit i think
he and i might be in agreement on this
there is a merit in the in a
transitional phase in continuing uh with
the uh the the use of of hydrocarbons in
this country uh rather than pointlessly
importing them from abroad
putin's imperial bloodlust won't stop at
ukraine we're rightly focused on
sanctions military and humanitarian
support and our commitment to ukrainian
freedom but the prime minister knows
there's been a phenomenal increase in
russian submarine activity over the last
20 years
our industry cables carry more than 95
of all western military diplomatic
commercial financial and personal
communications the consequences of these
cables being weaponised is terrifying
can he assure me that countering this
threat is part of our ongoing dialogue
with allies
she's absolutely right and uh that there
is a continual uh struggle going on
beneath the surface of the sea as she
knows uh between uh submarines that are
out to
sever uh cables and and and uh those of
us who are trying to make sure that
those links are maintained
so charles walker
mr speaker following on from my right
honorable and gallant friends question
about war crimes i suspect those crimes
are already being committed
by russian soldiers against their slavic
brothers and sisters
can the prime minister join with his
nato heads of state setting out at an
early stage how war crimes will be
prosecuted so all russian soldiers field
officers
generals and of course as the prime
minister said politicians are brutally
aware of where where they will end up
in a few years time
yeah yeah very good
is absolutely right
and that thank him i thank him very much
my honourable friend that's why we're uh
we're working on setting up a particular
international uh war crimes tribunal for
those involved in uh war crimes in the
ukraine theater
as well as being incredibly ruthless
president putin is also incredibly rich
with one assessment saying that his
personal wealth is up to 200 billion
dollars so can the prime minister ensure
that president putin himself
pays uh a heavy price by targeting his
own cash and assets
yes
absolutely uh mr speaker and not just
him uh but as the house has heard over
the last few days uh as many of his uh
immediate cronies and family as we can
hear
so battery
mr speaker and i thank the prime
minister for all that he's done uh just
before the statement i spoke to some of
the ukrainian protesters who are outside
one of them was holding back tears and
she spoke about her mother in a cellar
as a house is surrounded by ukrainian
tanks so any member of this house who's
asking for a negotiated settlement needs
to go and speak to them because all they
want is a deliver their lives as free
and peaceful people will the prime
minister confirm
to the people of ukraine that he will do
everything he can to end the tyranny of
putin and that he will do everything he
can to make sure that they live as a
peaceful and free people
yes i certainly can confirm that mr
speaker what i can also say is that i
believe uh in
this in by making this invasion that i i
think that uh president putin has done
uh more than anybody else to bring his
regime to an end because i think in the
end he will pay a huge price of what he
has done and i i know that this house
will want to make make it so
cold
thank you mr speaker
can i welcome and support the measures
um outlined by the prime minister uh
today
putin is a gangster on a despot who has
been trying to undermine and subvert
democracy across the world for years
one of the tools that he uses is through
political donations to political parties
including in this country will the prime
minister commit today to riddling
the democracy in london from uh to
dreading russian money out of democracy
in this country
yes of course mr speaker
thank you very much mr speaker estonia
latvia lithuania and poland today
triggered article 4 of the north
atlantic treaty and i think i heard that
we are going to be joining in those
discussions but can my writer will
offend assure our nato allies in eastern
europe that we stand firmly with them
particularly the baltic states that have
significant russian populations
thank uh very i thank you very much he's
completely right and that's why one of
the first things we did was to
strengthen our presence in uh in estonia
in the way that i've described
and uh our canadian friends are
strengthening their presence in in
latvia uh and uh we will make sure that
uh we give the the baltic states in
particular uh who who who seceded uh
from the soviet union who became free
and independent that amazing moment give
them all the security that they deserve
debbie abrahams
thank you mr speaker there's
overwhelming evidence that russian state
actors have been involved in trying to
disrupt and destabilize western
democracies using social media platforms
such as facebook so what is the
government doing to
to ensure that this isn't used in these
events
mr speaker as i said i think in an
answer uh a couple of days ago we've got
no evidence of of uh
disruption of uk uh elections or
electoral events as a result of uh of
russian activity but the online harms
bill
is there to provide such projections
mr speaker can i thank my right
honourable friend for his statement and
indeed thank the leader of her majesty's
opposition
for his supportive and moving words
but can i also reinforce the points made
by my honourable friend for huntington
why has it come to this past how has the
west in general and the united kingdom
in particular been so asleep at the
switch for such a long period of time
and it i commend the defense and
security review but isn't it now time to
ask what the permanent and impartial
machinery of our government does
failing to provide ministers with
consistent advice about the strategic
threats that our country faces
uh
mr speaker i think there are there are
all sorts of reasons for uh the failure
of the west to take sufficient account
of the threat of vladimir putin since
2014
uh but the
the the two biggest
uh are oil and gas
nick smith
mr speaker with cyber attacks and
falsehoods russia is peddling lies today
now observers on the ground are crucial
to relay the truth now in recent weeks
the uk has withdrawn its team from the
osce
special monitoring mission
because staff safety is key but can the
prime minister look again to support
international efforts like this to get
to the facts
and counter russian disinformation
i thank the mmr teams uh that they're
wonderful i've i've met them and and
they do a fantastic job i'm sorry that
they've had to be withdrawn for the for
the for the uh duty of care reasons that
he rightly uh alludes to and uh we will
keep it under constant review
liam fox
the 1994 budapest memorandum saw ukraine
give up its nuclear weapons in return
for a security guarantee not only signed
by britain and the united states but by
russia
does my right honourable friend believe
that ukraine would have been invaded had
it retained its nuclear weapons and what
does it say about the value of a russian
signature on any international agreement
well it's clear uh that uh president
putin uh sets no store by international
law whatever and he's uh that is just
one of the uh one of the one of the
legal obligations that he is torn up
justin black thank you very much mr
speaker we awoke this morning to images
of innocent families carrying in tube
stations
we know the putin regime's a propensity
for oppression and tourney particularly
when it comes to minorities
will the prime minister ensure that
humanitarian aid is delivered not just
in concert with other international
partners but also with third sector
organizations
yes of course so the third sector plays
an invaluable role thank you reg stuart
thank you mr speaker i welcome the prime
minister's statement and is specifically
ruling out the threat of creeping
normalization because this house should
be under no doubt that uh putin is well
prepared he has hundreds of billions of
foreign currency reserves he has a
military that has been tested and will
the prime minister do everything he can
to convert the current intent into
frameworks that cement
our intent over time because he is
betting on the fact that it won't be
my honorable friend is absolutely right
because the uh the the plan that uh the
g7 have agreed on and our friends and
partners have agreed on is that putin
must fail putin must not succeed in this
venture uh but we've got to put in place
all the steps we need to take
diplomatically
economically
and yes military in order to ensure that
that is the case and that's what we're
doing
the prime minister's right to have set
out the most stringent possible set of
sanctions against the government of
russia
can he outline for the house what the
implications will also be for
cooperation at the international space
station
i i i thank him i i thank him very much
i will have to see uh what what what
further downstream effects there are on
on collaboration of all kinds i must say
that hitherto
uh i have been broadly in favor of
continuing artistic and scientific uh
collaboration but uh in the current
circumstances it's hard to say see how
even those uh can continue as normal
so john hayes
speaker the mix of uh practice and
principle is the test of democratic
politics
exemplified at its best when this house
comes together in common cause
the test of leadership is the mix of
vision and will and the prime minister
is to be commended his willful clear
sighted determination
so will he now reassure the house that
he's in close touch with those countries
close to ukraine where nurse will be
frayed
and that will he send them an urgent
message that this house and this nation
will always stand alongside and behind
three nations
he's uh the right of gentleman as so
often is precisely right and that's why
uh together with my uh writable friends
the defense secretary foreign secretary
we've been visiting uh poland uh romania
uh the bolts uh all the all those who
who are now feeling such deep unease at
what is happening
alice to carmack thank you mr speaker as
we speak
the soft conflaut tanker ns challenger
is birthed at sulumbo in shetland taking
on a load of crude oil for export
softcom float as the prime minister may
know is a company owned and operated by
the russian government
my constituents mr speaker are asking me
why they should be loading oil onto a
russian tanker while russian troops are
marching into the ukraine i cannot think
of any good answer to give them
so can the prime minister tell me well
anything that he has announced today
ensure that that will not happen again
in the future
well i can tell him if i thank him very
much and i will i will of course
immediately investigate uh what what
is happening with the softcom float oil
tanker uh but the the result of the
measures that the house passed uh the
other day is that we can now target any
entity any company uh that has any
relation uh with the russian state so we
have that power
and megalomaniacs invade countries
because they think they can get away
with it and the way to deal with bullies
is to stand up with them so i'm sure he
will acknowledge that the way the west
responds to this aggression will have
repercussions not just for russia and
ukraine but for other bullies like china
as well and will he be mindful of the
need to show support to russians smaller
southerly neighbors especially georgia
and armenia who feel particularly
vulnerable at this time
yes i i thank him he's he's he's right
because the the read across the knock-on
uh is obvious for uh for georgia and
armenia what he what he proposes to
create uh putin is a new a new sphere of
influence a new yorker in which those
countries come behind his new iron
curtain thank you
thank you mr speaker as a member of this
house with ukrainian heritage
this issue particularly troubles me i'd
like to thank the prime minister for his
tone of his statement and the resolute
and swift action that he's proposing in
tackling russia but the resolute and
swift support is offering to the people
of ukraine
during his speech he also highlighted
the issues of the cost of living and the
rise of fuel prices could he also touch
on what further action the government
will take in order to address that issue
i thank him very much and i think he's
uh he's quite right because i think
people across the country will be
thinking about the effect on on us all
of the increase in the price of of oil
and gas as a result of uh a war in in
ukraine uh we will continue to do
everything we can to help people to
abate the cost and to support people
through uh through councils through all
the funds that were we're giving the the
uh the reduction in in council tax uh mr
speaker uh but the best thing that we
can do is ensure that people are in uh
good uh well-paying jobs and that is uh
in that we are certainly succeeding uh
but the in the in the medium
and the long term we've got to have more
self-reliance in this country on our own
energy supplies and that is that is what
this government is also uh committed to
building
jefferson
mr speaker one of the most important
economic sanctions we can take against
russia is by freezing its sovereign debt
will my right honourable friend confirm
that the bill proposed on monday on
economic crime will include powers to do
so
mr speaker we're taking the most uh
powerful uh measures against uh russia
and russia the russian economy that have
ever
been taken i think probably the most
powerful ever taken by any country and
uh russia will no longer be able to
raise uh any sovereign debt uh on uk
markets libya blake
thank you mr speaker um i'd like to ask
the prime minister what um support we we
will be providing ukrainian citizens
settled in the uk who wish to reunite
with their family members still residing
in ukraine many have watched their
cities rapidly rapidly get caught up in
this conflict and are keen to know what
more we could be doing to support them
to reunite their family
mr speaker we will make sure that we
support uh ukrainian nationals who
need to uh leave to visit there to come
to this country to uh to meet their
their uh their relatives of course we'll
do that steven mccarthy
thank you mr speaker i'm proud the prime
minister in this country are leading
international support for our friends in
ukraine domestically will the prime
minister be providing more support for
organizations such as our nhs public
sector organizations and businesses that
will now be the subject of russian cyber
attacks
he's right to point to this risk uh mr
speaker and and i i think he it's full
sighted we are we're investing massively
in uh in cyber protection i think
another 2.6 billion pounds we're putting
in uh i think in the last few years
we've tackled three thousand uh more
than three thousand uh cyber attacks it
is a risk uh it's a risk that i'm afraid
we must run in the cause of freedom
matt robert
thank you mr speaker and i'd like to
offer my wholehearted support for much
tougher sanctions against president
putin in his dreadful regime mr speaker
as the honourable gentleman from
lockerbie mentioned earlier there are
many historic ukrainian communities in
great britain and northern ireland and
indeed i would like to commend the work
of the reading ukrainian centre i would
like to ask the prime minister what
additional support can the government
give to these very valuable community
groups and centres around the country
who offer such support to families
friends relatives both in the uk and in
the ukraine
i think mr speaker perhaps the most
important thing we can do for the
ukrainian community in in these
countries
is is thank them recognize them for
everything that they've done for us in
the in the last uh decades they they've
been an amazing addition uh to the to
the uk to the uk economy uh to our
cultural and artistic life
thank you mr speaker
the house is united in its condemnation
but i suggest to the prime minister that
the lessons to be addressed from this
affair started with the invasion of
georgia russia's invasion georgia in
2008 and not 2014
and given you know many of us across the
house warned about have been warning
about russia and yet the response has
been weak does the prime minister accept
that as we enter the battle for
democracy globally we have got to
understand that the sooner you step you
you square up to the playground bully
the better
and that we adequately support our hard
and soft power to do that yeah
yes he is quite right and i know that by
soft power he's thinking of also the of
the british council uh which can have
such uh such a wonderful uh beneficial
effect uh across russia and i've seen it
i've seen its work across russia uh but
mr speaker he's right about standing up
to the to the playground bully we should
have done it uh ages ago i think the
scales have fallen from the eyes of many
of our friends and partners
philippa whitford
thanks very much mr speaker
in an earlier response the prime
minister suggested that this country
would welcome people who were reuniting
with family here i have a constituent
who's ukrainian but a british citizen
who's trying to bring her mother from
ukraine but being turned down because
she is over 18. her mother is on her own
has no family so naturally she's
frightened so will we see a change in
the home office to enable british
citizens who are ukrainian to bring
their vulnerable family here
yes i i thank you very much i think i
read out a helpline number in the house
uh uh on tuesday i don't have it again
there is a number both in both in libya
and in and in this country but if
there's if she could do me the favor and
send me the details uh we'll i'll take
them up
richard drax thank you mr speaker can i
commend my old friend and his ministers
for the firm stance they're taking
none of us know where or what mr putin's
aims longer term aims are
if ukraine falls and i fear it might his
covetous eye might land on the baltic
states and other vulnerable countries
can i write on my friend reassure
nato members that if one russian boot
lands on nato soil military force will
be met by military force
yes and what is so uh encouraging mr
speaker is that the whole house
understands uh the vital importance of
that article 5 guarantee that we make to
every one of the 30 members of nato
today
prime minister quite rightly puts this
as as being a battle between the party
of war and those who support
international law there is only one
lawful government in ukraine that's the
government of president chalenski if
they are forced to move for possibly
into exile in the short run or the
longer run will the prime minister state
very clearly that we will make sure they
can be a functional and effective
government wherever they operate from
it's a very important point that he
raises i'm grateful and that's why in
our discussions with uh president
zielinski we are seeing what we can do
to give them uh the practical uh support
that they need to continue
the city of london is a global asset
whose enduring success doesn't rest on
dirty money it rests on a commitment to
excellence
and in the adherence with the rule of
law so it's right that we now use that
as a way to show global leadership can i
encourage my right honourable friend to
sanction all of the remaining russian
banks to sanction the executives
associated with them and i notice that
many are resigning today to publish a
further list of individuals resident in
this country or otherwise to be
sanctioned and to redouble his excellent
efforts to suspend russia from swift as
the single most effective immediate step
that the west could do to put pressure
on vladimir putin
i i thank him very much i think i thank
him particularly for his important uh
testimonial uh to the city of london uh
whose work should not be uh should not
be sullied mr speaker by uh by
association with the ill-gotten uh
russian money but the the uh the the
program that he set out for sanctions is
exactly the right one and the one the
government is following like kane
i thank you mr speaker returning hate
for hates multiplies hates adding deeper
darkness to a night already devoid of
stars will the prime minister
reiterate that our quarrel is not with
the russian people it is with their
leader vladimir putin and he has
committed a very very grave error
he is so right and i know that that is
what the house
thinks we admire the russian people are
our links to the russian people go back
to the time when we stood shoulder to
shoulder to fight fascism uh with the
russian people uh russians russia's
contribution to uh culture to arts
literature is is is our music
unparalleled uh it is an extraordinary
country and nothing that we do or say uh
should obscure that shrub
winston churchill created the council of
europe as a bastion against fascism and
communism and since the fall of
communism russia has set great
importance by its membership as a fig
leaf of respectability every time our
conservative group has tried to get them
expelled we've been foiled by russian
gold will the prime minister now
instruct his ambassador on the council
of europe to move for the immediate
expansion of russia from the council of
europe so there is no place for
gangsters in the halls of civilized
nations
yes i think uh eloquently put mr speaker
and he's he's dead right and i think
that uh um my honourable friend for
henley made the the point uh the other
day and i certainly who's on the council
of europe i certainly agree with that
mr speaker so many russians today see
the attack on ukraine as they would see
an attack of their father on their
mother because there's such intimate
family relationships between these two
groups and today thousands of russians
are protesting in cities against their
domestic law against this awful war will
he provide them with his support will he
amplify their support to help reduce the
support any support there is for this
ridiculous war and also provide uh
sanction and safe haven for people
refugees including troops who may want
to re-engage uh the the troops outside
of ukraine so they can re-engage so we
can win this war at home and abroad
he makes a series of extremely important
observations and yes i think it's vital
that we uh that we get the message
across uh to the whole of russia about
what is really going on they're being
lied to uh day after day
and i think that is his point about uh
supporting troops who need uh uh
temporary exile as it were is a very
good one peter bell
thank you mr speaker i'd like to thank
the prime minister for yet again coming
to house to keep us informed and for his
leadership in this crisis
he was right to provide military aid to
ukraine
but the ukrainian ambassador did ask for
our support in a no-fly zone today and
he's a answer earlier i think the prime
minister was keeping that option open is
that correct
i think it's pretty clear to the highest
mr speaker that we're trying to keep all
our options uh open on this front uh
some of them frankly uh maybe more
practicable uh than others and i think
we have to we must also have a dose of
realism about what we can uh do on the
military front but uh we will keep all
things under review
rachel hopkins
thank you mr deputy speaker mr speaker
um many of my many of the residents in
my constituency come from a number of
the countries on the eastern flank and
still have relatives living there
obviously like us they'll be deeply
concerned about the humanitarian impact
of the uh crisis so
what steps is the government taking to
prepare for the
humanitarian issues and with the
thousand troops on standby to help with
humanitarian assistance will they now be
deployed
i think the uh
she raised a very important point and uh
what we're seeing now uh tragically is
is people moving west uh out of uh out
of kyiv uh columns of of traffic as i'm
sure the house knows uh we are people
already moving into uh into southeastern
poland uh
there is going to be an influx uh i i
said to the the president of uh of
poland prime minister of poland as well
uh we're there to help
laura trot thank you mr speaker and i
thank the prime minister for his
statement today and for his strong
package of sanctions
um i want to ask him about preventing
sexual violence in conflict
in november last year we issued a strong
statement which said that the use of
sexual violence as a weapon in conflict
is a red line akin to the use of
chemical weapons
will he reaffirm that commitment today
and will he send a strong message to
russia that the international community
will not tolerate the use of sexual
violence in conflict
yes and uh i think i thank her for all
the work that she's done on that on that
issue it's something that the uh the uk
government has campaigned on for for a
long time i mean indeed uh raised the
issue very greatly in uh public
international consciousness i think it
uh it should be treated
as a war crime like any other in people
who perpetrate sexual violence and in
conflict uh can expect uh to be tried at
that in those tribunals
shall maura
thank you mr speaker um in seeking to
redraw the boundaries of europe through
bloodshed
putin has attacked not only the ukraine
by all of us and we stand in with
ukraine and standing for the rule of law
i welcome the sanctions that he's
announced but i was confused by his
response on russian disinformation which
he seemed to imply would be addressed by
the online safety bill that is many many
many months away russian disinformation
is organized their bots are state
sponsored what steps would he take to
address them
i think we've got a
and she raised a good point but we've
got what we're doing is a massive uh
positive uh stratcom's campaign uh in in
russian in ukrainian uh to to make sure
that people get the truth and and they
hear the truth
thank you mr speaker
as we've noticed this afternoon
virtually everyone in this house has
supported the efforts
towards resistance over the last few
months and in these days i imagine the
house will also support the very
different sort of warfare under
occupation over the coming months and
possibly years
but the house will also have noticed the
marvelous way the prime minister has
spoken directly to the russian people
today
and i hope that he will bear in mind
that at the moment public opinion in
russia is rather different
that does underline the importance of
accurate information prime minister yes
he is he is quite right and uh
as a
i thank him he's a distinguished former
soldier and uh
he knows that uh truth is the first
casualty uh we have to be we have to
make sure that we are telling uh people
exactly what is going on and i and uh to
the best of my knowledge at the moment
uh the ukrainians are resisting much
more strongly uh than than some people
had thought that they would uh who knows
uh how long they can uh keep going let's
hope uh
they can and let's encourage them to do
so but mr speaker let's get the message
out
as well i think that is our that is our
job chris brian thank you mr speaker the
prime minister is absolutely right we
equivocated shamelessly after crimea we
were spineless we must not be spineless
now
because what will inevitably happen is
either the baltic states one of the
members of nato or perhaps sweden or
finland will feel the wrath of putin
next and that will mean
british
action
don't we need to try and set in train
now a process whereby putin himself ends
up in the dock in a court
norman
burkett said
who was the alternate british judge at
nuremberg
said at nuremberg initiating a war of
aggression is not only an international
crime it is the supreme international
crime differing only from other war
crimes in that it contains within itself
the accumulated evil of the whole
he must be brought to a court of law
and end his days in prison mustn't he
mr speaker i think one of the most
fascinating things about what putin uh
is doing is how close an analogy there
is between his actions and those of
slobodan milosevic uh exactly the same
nonsense being peddled about the
mystical union between kosovo uh and
belgrade as between kievand and moscow
exactly the same
aggression and remember that uh
milosevic died on trial
mark harper very much uh mr speaker i
welcome the package of sanctions set up
by the prime minister and the fact that
he's confirmed
more will come if they are to be
successful
at punishing president putin for what he
has done to date
and deterring him from going further and
attacking our nato partners they must be
sustained and if they're to be sustained
we must be honest with the british
people that there is going to be a cost
for them we are going to have to pay an
economic cost but it's a cost we must
pay and it is it pales into
insignificance compared to the cost of
the people of ukraine
yes and not only is that true mr speaker
but the opportunity
and the reward for success
and being
strong
is huge because if this should end uh mr
speaker with the rejection of aggression
and the rejection of the putin regime's
view of the world then that would be a
massive massive benefit and an economic
benefit as well to the whole world
mr speaker up until may 2021 valentina
jacqueline was my constituent she
resided in scotland for 20 years with
her daughter and her family but due to
an initial error in an application
she eventually exhausted appeals and was
deported with two covered jags last year
now that 71 year old is sheltering in a
subway um in response to the uh
honourable member for central airshirt
who's not our place and i would
reiterate does the prime minister agree
with me that as we face a likely refugee
crisis the uk must be doing all it can
to extract individuals who have
immediate family relatives in the uk and
urge for a support for this case
again i thank her very much for drawing
the case to my attention if she sends me
the details i'll be having to to make
sure it's properly taken up uh by the
home office
can i just say those who didn't get him
we have got a list for next time because
this will definitely not be the end okay
let people leave before i come to your
german
i beg to move this house to now a
journal the question is this host of
noah john wendy chamberlain
thank you mr speaker and we were told
this week by the prime minister that the
worst of kovid was over and we are
moving from responding to covert as a
crisis to something that we will be
living with in the long term thank you
madam deputy speaker and i hope and i
think that we all hope that the
government's assessment is right that
after two long years of sacrifice the
worst is over